hi my name is sonal and i'm working as a
senior analyst at captain
i did the data science master program
with simplylab and i feel proud that i
have taken the decision at the correct
time after working as a assistant
professor at an engineering college for
more than 11 years i felt stagnant in my
career data science has always been my
field of interest so i decided to take
the call that will define my career
finally
when i enjoyed my time teaching i wanted
to switch to the corporate sector but i
realized there was a gap
so to meet that i started looking for
the courses
i always aspired to build a career in
data science field and the simply law
force acted as the catalyst in my career
development i left my job in january
2020 and took up the data science master
course
what made this decision easy for me was
the competency content
and the brand value of simply lost
certifications that our top msa
acknowledged it
since the beginning the trainers were
very friendly and helped me understand
everything by clearing all the doubts
by doing the course i got a chance to
work as a fund research data at crystal
limited which was a great use for me and
made my belief sure that i'm going on
the right path the course helped me
improve my resume and stand apart from
other candidates in front of the
recruiters
after finishing my course and getting
the certificate i started looking for
the better career opportunities the
certification helped me develop much
needed skills in the field of data
science especially python and tableau
and finally helped me to get hired as a
senior analyst at capgemini
consistency is very important in
whatever you do
i am to apply the corporate ladder and
currently i have taken some more courses
from simply learn to keep up skilling i
believe age is no bar when it comes to
learning all you need to do is to choose
the correct path and get the proper
guidance